Welcome back everyone it's Charlie
Marvel and Kevin Feige announced their
complete Marvel phase four schedule a
while ago they also recently revealed
most of the first few years of their
Marvel phase 5 schedule and because of
that we have a much better idea for
what's actually going on with Avengers 5
and when they're actually going to
release it if you're new to my channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos we're doing that new infinity
saga box set giveaway for all the
blu-rays all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave all your
predictions for Avengers 5 on the video
the weird thing that happened is after
avengers endgame i saw a lot of comments
and my various feeds all over social
media from random people that for
whatever reason no joke thought that
Marvel was never going to do another
Avengers movie maybe they never read any
Marvel or Avengers comics or they just
don't understand how the Avengers work
as a team but there will be more
Avengers movies news flash I feel like
that's not a revelation but because of
all these announcements recently we have
a much better idea for what that's going
to look like so we'll just break this
down top 5 style so number 5 in the past
during the Avengers infinity saga of
movies which is what they're calling all
23 movies starting with Iron Man 1
ending with Spider Man far from home I
know Spider Man far from home feels like
a Marvel phase 4 movie because it
happens after avengers endgame but
technically it's Marvel phase 3 because
it's meant to be an epilogue for
avengers endgame but during the infinity
saga Avengers movies typically released
at the end of each different phase phase
1 just lasted a little bit longer for
years because they had to introduce all
the different characters in their own
movies before they came together but
Avengers age of Ultron came out three
years after the first Avengers movie at
the end of Marvel phase two then three
years after that Avengers infinity war
came out at the end of Marvel phase
three avengers endgame is kind of a
special case and that it started out as
a Part two movie even though the plot is
very different so it's a weird situation
but it's basically back-to-back with
infinity war so if Marvel releases an
Avengers big event movie at the end of
each phase normally you would expect
them to end Marvel phase four with
Avengers 5 but they released the
complete phase 4 schedule and there's no
Avengers movie anywhere to be found why
did they do that
number 4 mostly to have a
cooling-off period and avoid
oversaturation with the Avengers brand
and because marble pays for is only a
two-year period instead of the
traditional three years worth of movies
we've typically gotten in the previous
two phases and two years between
Avengers endgame in Avengers five just
isn't enough time to build the story
they need for Avengers five there's a
formula for these big Avengers movies
the model they follow is basically
number one introduce new cool
superheroes that have their own
adventures to then introduce a problem
so big that none of them could face it
on their own and they have to team up
then three also lay the seeds for an
even bigger Cataclysm universe
shattering event that'll happen eight to
ten years down the road your Herald
summons you another world awaits let it
be done quickly Kevin Feige revealed
back at comic-con that they are
following this model for the next big
Avengers team-up they're laying the
seeds for their next big Avengers
endgame level event that's going to happen
eight to ten years down the road so when
you look at the Marvel phase four
schedule again they released a comic-con
they're not really introducing that many
huge New Avengers level characters like
shang-chi will be in Avengers five a few
the Eternals characters like Kit
Harington are probably in a show up
during Avengers five Thor doesn't really
count because he's not a new character
even though he's going to come back for
Avengers five and obviously we all
expect spider-man to come back but he's
not a new character either so Marvel
phase four is kind of a transition phase
finishing movies with older characters
that they didn't get to before like
Black Widow and slowly introducing new
weird stuff like the Eternals
but that by itself isn't enough for a
totally new Avengers roster so number
three the Marvel phase five schedule in
all the Avengers levels sinister six
spider-man movies I consider all the
Marvel Sony's sinister six spider-man
stuff to be huge big event crossovers
like The Avengers movies but this video
is mostly just about the Marvel Avengers
stuff right now this is the Marvel phase
5 schedule Marvel announced all these
dates and since this was made a couple
months ago they've also announced what
some of these movies are but this is the
official first few years of the Marvel
phase 5 schedule it's not complete I'll
talk about why in a second but Marvel
announced all these dates and since this
was made they also announced with some
of these other new movies are going
to be you also notice this is pretty
cool they're doing four movies a year
starting next year to during Marvel
phase four but Marvel phase five starts
in 2022
so between then and 2023 based on the
movies that they've announced in the
ones they've said that they've started
working on here's what's probably
happening I'm going to list all these in
order of release date starting with the
February 2022 movie first one on the
docket is ant-man three thank you very
much Michael Douglas for leaking the
production dates on that we only know
that Cassie Lange is coming back she's
still technically a teenager primed to
join a young Avengers team at some point
they'll continue dealing with the
quantum realm they spent so much time
setting up the quantum city and all the
stuff going down there during ant-man
and the wasp they're just going to continue
pushing into that during ant-man 3 then
there's black panther 2 revealed back at
d23 by kevin feige
there's been a lot of rumors about them
introducing x-men Fox characters during
this but they're still just rumors they
haven't confirmed which big villains
they're going to include one of the
biggest rumors is that Doctor Doom is
going to show up during Black Panther 2
and part of that is because Fantastic
Four marvel's Fantastic Four is also
rumored to be the next big summer movie
coming out that year they've already
started working on it secretly we just
don't know how far along they are in
development so hopefully things go well
with that and they'll make some public
announcements in the next year then the
last movie during 2022 is supposed to be
Deadpool 3 right now which Ryan Reynolds
announced a few weeks ago just based on
the amount of time it takes them to
produce it and when they could actually
get it out the Marvel people Ryan
Reynolds people have been talking about
Deadpool 3 for a while I've already done
videos about that stuff so I'll link it
at the end of this but number 2 we're
now in the 2023 movies row this is the
second year of Marvel phase 5 starting
with the February movie
we have guardians of the galaxy volume 3
which James Gunn and the cast have been
talking about for a while now I know
he's been really cagey about Adam
warlock but that's basically where Adam
warlock is supposed to show up then
there's Captain Marvel 2 which they just
announced they started working on last
week then Spiderman for which Marvel and
Sony announced awhile ago
spider-man 4 is going to come out two
years after spider-man 3 which is
came out two years after spider-man far
from home which it came out two years
after spider-man homecoming Sony really
loves that spider-man money so that's
why those movies come out on such a
predictable schedule then the last movie
of 2023 would be Marvel's blade which
they announced back at Comic Con
they're not in a big rush to make blade
mostly because they're still sort of
setting the stage for Supernatural
characters but that's not all the Marvel
phase 5 movies because Avengers 5 will
be coming at the end of Marvel phase 5
which is that next year in 2020 for
Avengers movies are always released in
the spring so late April early May 2024
book your Avengers 5 tickets
all of that is spoilers but I'm
extremely excited about those characters
and about and about bringing Marvel's
first family up sort of to the platform
and the level that they deserve so
number one you're all asking why wait
five years to do Avengers 5 why
don't you do it a little bit sooner than
that the whole reason as you've probably
guessed is because of the x-men the new
Marvel versions of the x-men characters
and I'm talking about the big a-list
x-men characters so that's also part of
the reason why you're not seeing
marvel's uncanny x-men anywhere on the
schedule before Avengers 5 here in 2023
or 2022 or even sooner than that they
could actually make an x-men movie
tomorrow if they wanted to they got the
rights back last year the main reason
why they're waiting so long to do that
though is because it takes a couple of
years to develop a good movie and we all
want them to make a good x-men movie and
they want as much distance between their
marvel x-men movie in the Fox x-men
movies Dark Phoenix did so badly at the
box office everyone over there is kind
of hoping that the next few years things
will cool off and the general public
will completely forget it ever existed
but if you're bummed out that they're
not going to be doing big big x-men stuff
and big x-men characters like Wolverine
for 4 to 5 years don't worry because
they're using black panther to the
Marvel phase 5 films to sort of set up
the concept of x-men like we have the
Scarlet Witch 1 division series coming
up and Doctor Strange 2 into the
multiverse of madness and they've been
teasing all this reverse no more mutants
Scarlet Witch stuff she is already a
mutant in the MCU they've already
canonized that
some tie-in books but I know you're all
just waiting for the a-list characters
like when are we going to see the next
Wolverine when is all that going to
happen for the most part I'm just really
excited to see what their new Marvel
Fantastic Four are going to look like in
what Deadpool 3 is actually going to wind
up looking like so everyone post all
your predictions for Marvel's new x-men
characters and Avengers 5 and there'll
be a whole bunch more Marvel stuff
happening this week there's going to be a
Black Widow Superbowl trailer so of
course I'll do a video for that everyone
click here for my new Marvel Eternals
teaser breakdown and click here for my
new Deadpool 3 video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome
maximum effort